the streets of the mexican capital are
returning to their usual hustle and
bustle
an easing of coronavirus restrictions is
allowing many people to return to work
since the start of the health emergency
mexico's economy has been battered
leaving millions in dire straits
i have to support the children and
support the son-in-laws and most of all
the grandchildren
it's chaos then there's not even enough
to eat i mean it it
is very difficult for us
because of the state of the economy we
can't just stay home we have to keep
moving
but people who go out and aren't careful
they go to parties or gatherings when
they know they shouldn't
that's unacceptable i do not agree with
that
after more than two weeks since testing
positive for covet 19
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador has resumed his daily press
conferences
the president has been criticized for
downplaying the severity of the outbreak
and for almost never wearing a mask in
public
why did i get infected because like
millions of other mexicans i have to go
to work
fortunately i got through it and here we
are still fighting
mexico's government has struggled to
curb coronavirus contagion
even under orders to shut down
non-essential services coronavirus cases
have continued to spike
much of the pressure to lift the most
recent lockdown has been led by
restaurant owners
mexico's food service industry has been
among the worst hit by the economic
downturn
an agreement between business owners and
city officials means restaurants have
expanded their hours of operations
though new sanitation measures only
allow for outdoor
seating to reduce the risk of contagion
those facing the highest risks however
are the country's nearly 30 million
informal sector workers caught in a
country where the coronavirus pandemic
has forced people indoors and an
economic crisis
that's left them no option but to take
to the streets in search of work
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city